filthy stiffs tension is what works best
for both of us and that's what's in what
what how it plays out then great if not
shoot let's go how the heck with 2019
and we'll worry about 2020 when we need
to worry about it so I figure out with
every intention of bringing the
quarterback in 2020 here so it's not for
any reason other than just st. I thought
I signed up for this been a year the
mission is one of the last year right
let's go that's what's best so I really
do so teach about it and it feel good
it's been four years since Philip Rivers
entered the final year of a contract
before he could get there the Chargers
intervened and signed him to a new deal
now the question becomes what will the
Chargers do Philip Rivers getting closer
and closer to 40 you could argue that
there are some signs that his game is
beginning to diminish he fully intends
to stick around for 2020 even though he
doesn't have a contract for 2020 the big
unknown in all this big hat is what do
the Chargers want to do they flirted
with Marcus Mariota four years ago there
was talk a couple of years ago about
maybe them being interested in to Shaun
Watson I feel like they've at least been
exploring their options they've yet to
find a better option than Philip Rivers
but if he's starting to go the other way
it's gonna be easier to find somebody
else that they think can come in and
play as well they may not want him for
2020 even if he wants to be there I mean
he was fantastic last year had a great
great season not his career-high or
anything but a great season I do agree
the arm strength is kind of waning a
little bit you see it with Drew Brees
you see it with Phil Rivers you see it
with other guys who are getting up there
in age even Tom Brady maybe not has the
same arm strength but Philip Rivers
still has the mind for the game and he
can still win you football games
Chargers still had a fantastic season I
will be interesting to me Mike is wood
Phillip Rivers
be interested in a short term low cost
deal so the Chargers can maybe get a
little frisky and free agency and load
up for a run for him and for LA in their
new stadium and all that coming up in
2020 could you see something like that
because I you know Phil Rivers might say
hey look I want
contend I want to play playoff football
I'll take less let's get everyone going
here let's get a a load up on the
defense let's load up on the offense
give me one or two more shots to try to
win a Super Bowl because that's really
it Phillip Rivers is a Hall of Famer if
he can win a Super Bowl now we're
talking a different class especially
when you have Big Ben and Eli Manning
the draft class that he will always be
linked to both with two Super Bowls and
you know you make a great point there's
a ruthlessness snare that the Chargers
may apply to Phillip Rivers from the
standpoint of hey you want to keep
playing for us this is all we're paying
you we can't justify paying you more not
where you currently are in your career
we will pay you X and you can either
take it or you can go play somewhere
else and uproot all those kids you have
that that's the weird thing about this
the idea of Phillip Rivers ever leaving
the Chargers where would he go taking
nine kids and Counting in tow with him
he's not gonna go for four months and
live alone somewhere he's too connected
and loyal to his family and that's a
good thing but you know the Chargers and
we've seen this from time to time where
a team will use that against the guy
that they think is never gonna leave and
that's how the Vikings ultimately lost
Matt Burke to the Ravens they thought
he'd never leave he's got a bunch of
kids he's not gonna go anywhere else and
at some point it becomes a challenge to
who you are and he said hey and then the
player says screw it I'm gonna go
somewhere else but the Charter you may
try to do it there's a chance if they do
it it'll blow up on them it's a great
point especially knowing that Phil
Brewers I think still lives in San Diego
and commutes to the facility in the LA
area so it's obviously not a long
commute but that story written about how
he sits in a big van and watches tape on
his commute because he didn't want to
uproot his family to answer your
question the Dolphins are always
available so he could go play for the
Dolphins in 2020 I have a question for
you though Mike Phillip Rivers Ben
Roethlisberger Eli Manning that draft
class it's an unbelievable draft class
those guys put up insane numbers they'll
all be in Kenton who will who will take
the last snap NFL snap of those three
brought this burger
I think I'd be wrong he's when he signed
his latest contract the way it's
structured it's a it's a three-year deal
it's a two-year extension the way they
did the signing bonus he's not retiring
for three years and they're not getting
rid of him for three years
they know what it's like to not have a
franchise quarterback they had 20 years
between Terry Bradshaw our IP and Ben
Roethlisberger and and that they're not
gonna push Roethlisberger out the
question is how much longer who will he
play beyond these next three years Kevin
Kolbert the GM of the team told me last
week that there's no expiration date on
Roethlisberger and he very well may play
beyond 2021 so he's gonna be the last
one of that group to play well there's
no expiration on Roethlisberger unless
he gets an offensive coordinator again
that he doesn't like because remember he
almost retired because it's hot hailey
last year or two years ago I wouldn't I
wouldn't sleep on Phil Rivers being the
last quarterback take a snap because I
do think he loves football and yeah the
arm strength I mean he's never been a
super arm strength guy but big montt and
his mind is there and coming off a
season like he's had I think he wants to
keep playing and then the dark horse
obviously is Eli Manning because Dave
Kettleman might play Eli Manning for the
next decade like that might just be on
the table here where Eli Manning is
playing til he's 50 and they're in they
keep doing the same date on Jones never
even takes a snap for the Giants if you
told me that I wouldn't say you're that
crazy I'd say there's maybe a 1 or 2
percent chance that could happen you
know we talked about this yesterday
though thanks for watching the show
I think the fact that they took Daniel
jones sixth overall is the clue that's
out there in plain sight that tells us
what the Giants are gonna do we were
talking yesterday about the chance that
Jones ends up being the week 1 starter
and Manning isn't even with the team
anymore you never know with the Giants
at this but you know with the Giants you
never know what they say about oh hey we
didn't sign him to trade him what did
they do
I'm just saying RJ Manning runs that
team if he did they went to drafted
Daniel Jones
no that's exactly what a dude draft
Daniel Jones because he's got the
Manning ties he's got the Cutcliffe ties
you draft someone that you know that you
can control Archie Manning made a genius
draft pick with Daniel Jones because he
knows them he grew up in the Manning
passing camps he's not going to be a
threat to Eli Manning going forward if
Philip Rivers leaves the Chargers keep
an eye on the Titans there were rumors
four years ago of a Marcus Mariota
flip-flop where the Chargers would have
given the Titans Rivers and gotten the
second overall pick and taken Mariota if
the Titans decide to move on from
Mariota Philip Rivers Tennessee Titans
finishing his
career there don't rule that out it just
it just makes enough sense probably to
never happen but maybe it will we're
gonna take a quick break we got a full
hour of pro football talk live still to
come we'll be back with more right after
this
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports